bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors ça a été a voté
les néonicotinoïdes sont réintroduits
est-ce que vous avez une réaction
disons qu'on a vu un gouvernement une
majorité très divisé sur un sujet où il
a été pris entre la nécessité de choisir
d'une part entre la nécessité de
sauvegarde d'un secteur sinistré celui
de l'industrie sucrière de la betterave
et en même temps des impératifs
environnementaux qui ont été affichés
comme une des priorités du gouvernement
notamment avec madame compliqué numéro
trois du gouvernement et qu'il ya
quelques années avait porté très haut le
combat pour l'interdiction de ces
pesticides donc là on voit qu'ils
étaient un peu pour certains pris à
aarau bora avec la nécessité de défendre
une loi pour lequel l'abrogation en gros
d'une loi dans lequel ils avaient voté
il ya très peu de temps le gouvernement
a promis de mettre l'écologie au centre
de ses priorités
ce projet de loi aurait pu finalement
faire figure de teck de test est ce que
cette loi est ce que ca atteint peu le
recul du gouvernement en matière de
défense de l'environnement c'est en tout
cas l'avis partagé par les écologistes
alors disons que oui il ya eu une
critique très nette des écologistes
d'europe écologie les verts ou du
nouveau groupe écologie sociale qui vit
ici la majorité sur cette polémique
et on voit que notamment pour la
ministre elle est mise en difficulté à
devoir défendre des intérêts économiques
aux dépens d'intérêt de santé humaine et
environnementale
alors même que c'était son combat il ya
quelques années
donc on voit que pour le gouvernement ça
va être un nouvel épisode
sa difficulté à asseoir sa crédibilité
sur ces sujets environnementaux
alors le gouvernement a réintroduit ces
pesticides pour sauver la filière
betterave
les écologistes ont manifestement
proposer d'autres alternatives en
refusant les écouter ne va-t-on pas vers
la rupture alors avec ta départ et quel
type d'écologie depuis qu'avec par
exemple peut aller la rupture avec le
gouvernement est déjà très nette
et puis avec les autres figures et
écologistes certains sont déjà très
indépendant de la majorité
présidentielle mais c'est surtout en
terme d'image que ça pose problème
puisque la grande partie en tout cas des
électeurs macro ni sont plutôt plutôt
une certaine sensibilité écologique et
sont aussi plutôt des gens qui vivent
dans les villes et là on est sur une
exception à la loi des pesticides qui
est plutôt défendu par les milieux
ruraux les gens qui ont conscience de
l'importance de ce genre de pesticides
pour la sauvegarde d'un secteur agricole
donc on n'a pas seulement un clivage et
idéologique on a aussi un clivage urbain
rural sûr c'est sur ces sujets françois
kraus merci d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt frange rappelle que vous
êtes directeur du pôle politique de
l'ifop merci